So our intention today is to go over
graph data science and specifically
leveraging Neoforj's property graph for
doing graph data science. We can go in a
number of directions and especially when
we have a really small group. What I
like to do is speak directly to whatever
your questions may be. So if you f are
you guys open to us kind of rolling a
little bit and getting a little more
information about what you're working on
things like that? Anyone? Yeah. Um who
here has you done data science on graphs
previously?
Okay. Yes. Yes. No. New. Okay. Um what
kind like are there certain types of
algorithms you usually work with
certain use cases you're working on
one of my favorites I love between the
centrality awesome okay um and what are
you using right now what are you running
your um graph data science how are you
what kind of a library are you using
right
Oh, you are. Okay, cool. All right. So,
this will probably not be new to you,
but what I want to make sure is if you
have more advanced questions, I'm a good
person to ask. So, definitely let me
know. Mostly what we were going to do
was general, but we'll see. Um, and
you've done graph data science before.
What have you mostly worked on? So we
are trying to different but mostly I
would say detection one.
>> Yeah.
>> Y
>> also based on
it's always good time to
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely. Um
I'm just kind of surveying the audience
right now to see who's used who's done
data science on graphs before.
Yes. Yes. Maybe. No. A little bit. Okay.
All right. Um,
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
go over all the general pieces, right?
Like I mean we go we always go through
nodes and properties just because um and
we'll go through we're going to be using
the Neoforj sandbox just so that we can
get in and just start playing with some
things that everybody can follow along
with. But what I really want everyone to
do is to as we're going through these
variety of algorithms today, really be
thinking about your use case. And if
it's something you're already working
on, is there something that you're stuck
on? Is there something that you want to
talk through? Because whenever we do
workshops, we really want to make sure
that everybody gets something that moves
them forward. So if there's something in
particular, the biggest thing is don't
be shy. Sound good? Awesome. Okay.
All right. All right. It is going to be
Do I Do I have to use this?
>> What's that? [snorts]
>> Oh, it's Yeah, it's hard to It's hard to
type and hold the microphone at the same
time, but that's okay. We'll be all
right. We'll We will figure this out. I
am a professional. Um,
all right. This is a part where we talk
about the things everybody knows
already. Just kidding. Um, obviously
we've got uh, you know, the the movie
database comes up a lot. So we're going
to talk about nodes obviously in
reference to the movie database. A node
as we know is a thing often representing
a noun of some kind. And we have this
beautiful item called the label which
yes.
>> Oh, how do I do that?
>> Larry's going to help my technical
abilities here.
And we're doing live stuff, too. So,
>> okay, you can share that.
>> Okay. All right.
So, yeah. So, generally your nodes are
going to be representing things. Um, and
then we've got the label, which tells
you which type of a node it is. It's
giving you a category. Uh, one thing
that you can, Has anybody here ever done
double labeling? Use multiple labels on
their nodes? Yes. if you haven't, it can
be super helpful. So, just keep that in
your back pocket. We do that a lot. Uh,
and obviously these nodes have
properties, which is the information
about that node. And then there are
relationships among these
relationships also have every Yeah,
everybody's good on nodes and
relationships. That's kind of what I
figured, but they always put them in
there just in case, right? Um so when we
talk about the about graph data science
what we're really trying to figure out
are we're looking at a specific set of
algorithms that generally can only be
solved by graph. So for example, if
we're looking at the the London subway
system and we're at Liverpool Street and
we need to get to Waterlue, the question
is what's the best way to get there? And
depending on this is a a classic path
finding and the question is which way do
we get there? Well, that all depends. We
have a we can take the circle line,
right? Liverpool, what is it? I I what?
Oh, Tower Hill embark embankment and
then Waterlue, right? This seems
reasonable, right? Let's go that route.
But what we're seeing here is we have
the properties that are actually the
time. How long does it take to get from
one station to the next? And so we can
see that if we take the circle line,
it's going to give us 28 minutes. If we
go central to Jubilee, we can see it's
only going to take 24 minutes because
the amount of time it takes to get from
one station to the next is going to be
less. So this is a classic path finding.
You see it obviously we use these every
day in our ways. I think everybody used
it today to figure out which was the
best train for us to get here from where
we were. Um, you know, we have
relationships and questions. But right
now, what we're going to do is, um,
we're going to go into Neo4j sandbox.
So, anybody who wants to work along
because we love clicking and typing in
workshops. Um, you can go to
sandbox.neforj.com
and get yourselves logged in. and we're
going to go in and use the graph data
science sandbox. Let me go let me take
this out. Go into a new project.
Yeah, you're going to get yourself
signed in. But when you get signed in,
you're going to select a project. And
you'll see one that says graph data
science, which I already have open,
which is why we're not I'm not seeing it
right now. But um you should be able to
get to the select a project page in
sandbox.neforj.com.
There's a
Come on, sandbox.
And then you're going to find a graph
data science project that you want to
start.
Um, the good thing about the sandbox
right now is that you can actually open
up a blank sandbox. We also we have a
couple other ways that you can use
Neoforj, but specifically for graph data
science. Right now, sandbox is a great
way to do it for your own purposes. If
you want to um work on something later,
we've got the blank uh a blank sandbox
that you can use as well. So, if you
want to run your own things, right now
sandbox runs three days, Martin, I
think.
>> You can extend it to seven. Yeah. So if
you just want to get in and PC something
and use some graph data science, that's
a great way to use it. We also have a
number of people that use community
edition. Is there anybody here who has
used Neo4j before?
Oh, yes. Okay. All right. So we're we're
preaching to the choir here.
Um All right. So we're going to go into
the graph data science project. I don't
want that one. Why did I open a new one?
It's not what I meant. All right.
And what it's going to do is it's going
to open Neo4j browser. Um in the sandbox
we have a series of walkthrough and
we're going to walk through a variety of
different types of algorithms.
See here we go. So for those of you who
are there's probably not too many but
I'm going to give the speech anyway. For
those of you who are newer to graph data
science specifically, you might be more
familiar with traditional machine
learning. And in traditional machine
learning we have different areas.
Obviously we have supervised and
unsupervised machine learning. And then
within these we certainly have
clustering, dimensionality reduction, um
different types of associations. And
then on the more supervised side we have
our um regressions and classifications.
And when we look at graph data science,
we have these these parallel almost
types of algorithms. Not all exactly the
same, but we still have clustering. We
still have dimensionality reduction. We
still have association. But they're a
little bit different because they're
leveraging the graph itself. So for
example, when we look at community
detection, it's not based on individual
features or uh it's some of the math and
the calculations are similar, but there
are different elements and different
mathematics that become available
because we are using graph and we're
looking at a graph structure.
So when we think about um path finding
and search these are all the algorithms
and actually I don't think this is even
all of them but these are all of the
algorithms that are in um Neo4j's graph
data science library and depending on
what you're trying to accomplish there's
usually many ways to do it and each of
them is going to have their own
mathematical piece associated with it.
Obviously, some of the ones that come up
a lot are, you know, your shortest path
comes up quite a bit. Um, you know,
people already have talked about page
rank, my favorite between the
centrality. Um, we've done a lot of work
with I've done a lot of work with using
centrality algorithms for risk
identification and systems. So, I do
that a lot. Community detection. We're
actually doing a lot of community
detection even in our Genai applications
right now. So using um you know
similarity scoring across your content
so that you can see like if you have
duplications or um different pieces like
that. So there's a lot happening there
you know clearly supervised machine
learning link prediction um like we
talked about similarity. So and there's
lots of work being done with the graph
embeddings as well as um you know I I
personally like graph embeddings myself.
Um, and then the graph embeddings, it's
a matter of being able to use that
structure of the local node as an
embedding. I know there's research being
done on path embeddings, which like I'm
still waiting on. I'm like, "Oh, I want
a path embedding, right?" Like, who
doesn't get excited about path
embeddings? So, you know, I bring up the
the laundry list of all the things that
we have because
one of the nice things about the the
team at Neo4j is this is all we do and
we spend a lot of time optimizing the
algorithms. I just we just had a
presentation from someone in our
research department yesterday about the
different pieces that they're working on
as well. So we definitely encourage you,
we've got lots of open source ways that
you can use this particular library and
community edition. Um so if you're
already in this space, just know that
there are there's a whole series of
algorithms that are available to you um
that we're working on right now.
All right. So we're going to talk about
like a little bit about some of the
types of algorithms that we have. Um, in
I'm going to go through a little bit of
the math underneath the community
detection. Let me ask you this. Is
anyone curious about the math under
community detection? Okay, we've got one
a couple. Okay. All right. So, we'll go
through and do this. Um, so what is
community detection? Community detection
detection is a clustering algorithm,
right? So, for example, how likely are
these nodes to be clustered? um how how
likely are these things to be grouped
together versus broken apart? And so the
use cases that we see obviously customer
segmentation recommendations um entity
resolution is we use all the time
sometimes fraud detection um and also
like I said we're using it a lot right
now in our Genai applications to do
clustering of um content and clustering
of documentation for um a number of
different reasons. There's actually this
is actually a really interesting one
that just came up recently. Um I was
talking to someone who was they were
using Neo4j to look at historical risk
planning in you know military operations
and trying to see like you know what
like you'll have a military op and
they'll be like okay this was the
strategy and that they did is they went
through and they were doing a genai
application with it and what they found
was that a lot of people cut and paste
from one document to another but they
found that Some of them were going back
like 30, 40 years and they just kept
getting copy and pasted like
methodologies moving forward and they're
like we should probably update those. We
didn't know they were that old because
you don't see that lineage. And so
there's a lot of really interesting
things that you can do now. So also as
we go through the algorithms, you know,
be open to ways that it can be that some
of the algorithms that you wouldn't
traditionally find with whatever it is
that you're working on can be really
helpful. So just something that we've
been seeing a lot of um
cross-pollination of algorithms. So when
we look at community detection right
now, we're looking at a couple groups of
friends and we can clearly see from the
structure because there's only six of
them that we clearly have two different
groups. But when we start getting into
large numbers, understanding where does
one community end and another begin can
get very very messy and spaghetti like.
So one of the things that we have is we
have something called a component. Um
you'll find an algorithm called weekly
connected components. And what it does
is it identifies all of the unique
subgraphs that are within your graph.
Right? Um so weekly connected components
it's identifying all the disjointed
subgraphs that you have. I a lot of
times people will use first they'll use
weekly connected components to identify
how many individual subgraphs do we have
but also it can be a pre-processing step
for some of the other algorithms that
you're going to talk about because some
of the algorithms that you're going to
want to run are going to need to be on a
completely connected graph. So keep in
mind that sometimes being able to
identify um you know if there's
something that's disjointed or not
connected sometimes what we'll do is
we'll use that as a pre-processing to
cleave off parts of the graph that are
not going to run because we need a fully
connected graph for um the algorithm to
run. Any questions on that idea? Does
that make sense to folks who are newer?
Okay, cool.
Um so yeah so really we're just looking
to find what each of those are when we
run. So I like to give a few of these
sort of features of different algorithms
weekly connected components it does
treat everything as undirected and it's
unweed by default because we're not
concerned we're only concerned about
them being connected or disconnected not
like the you know the force of that. Um
obviously the algo the algorithm is
homogeneous and it's very very fast
right so that's why it's a pretty easy
one.
A lot of when we start talking about
some of our graph algorithms we have a
mathematical unit called modularity. Has
anybody here heard of modularity before?
No. Okay. All right. So um and it's a
way of recognizing sort of how how
interconnected a community is. So if
there's high modularity that means that
it's really well connected to itself and
it's weakly connected to other portions
of the graph and other areas. So what
the what it's going to do is it explores
every node and it says okay if this node
is here or not does the overall
modularity for this community go up or
down right and so like does it increase
if it changes its community from one of
its neighbors to another right so what
does that actually look like so the way
that it the Louane algorithm for an
example which is like one that we use
quite a bit is it'll start at a random
node and what it will do is it will say
okay if every every neighbor that I'm
connected to is this node and then it'll
go to the next one and it'll
automatically just create like a series
of um a series of default numbers and
default assignments and then what it's
going to do is it's going to continue
that process and say okay well now these
are my these are my neighbors and this
is um like how interconnected it is. So
what we see here in this next step is
this says how many how many um
relationships do we have from blue nodes
to other blue nodes versus from a blue
node from the blue community to the
green community. And so it just
continues to iterate that way and that's
how it says oh well this is this is how
we're going to settle on that. So you
know this shows you in the end like what
the modularity would actually look like.
So it says, you know, the the math of
how connected am I to my own group
versus to the others. Um if anybody
remembers like uh from traditional
machine learning silhouette scores, does
that sound familiar to anyone? Yeah,
it's the same kind of thing. So in here,
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to find the optimal modularity based on
each of these um with this node set up
in these connections. I mean looking at
it we can probably guess which one was
going to have the highest modularity but
what it does is it actually shows you it
shows you sort of the calculation like
if everything's in one then your
modularity is zero because it can't be
connected to anything else. Um and then
when we have one for each one they're
going to be really low too. So just to
know that when we're going through and
running these algorithms, most of the
time you're going to see this concept of
modularity in the documentation on your
community detection algorithms. And this
is what we're talking about. So how
tightly connected am I to each other
versus the others? And again, the way
that you're going to see it is when
something is at its peak modularity,
you're going to find really high numbers
of interconnection and really low
numbers cross-connecting to the other
communities
questions.
Yes.
>> I just
You mean uh so do you mean before you
run the algorithm or after?
>> No, after when I see the result.
>> Yeah.
>> I actually don't really know what
relationships.
>> Well, I mean the the relationships are
going to be the pre-existing
relationships that you have, right? So
these relationships are all what was
already in the the data that we passed
to the algorithm. So those relationships
aren't going to change. They're still
going to be the same relationships they
had. But if you wanted to do that, this
calculation, if you wanted to get this
actual calculation here, is that the
question? Could you get that?
>> I just I just want to know which are the
connections that connect the components.
>> You're talking about Oh, which are these
three here? So, for example, Yeah. So,
the the purple and the yellows, it's
look like Well, I only see two. Maybe
the math is a little bit bad. Um, but
it's just going to be whichever
relationships there are between those
communities and is Oh my god, this thing
um is is what we're seeing in between
these here.
Yeah.
Break my ankle on that thing. Um
other questions
and there's lots of different ways to go
through and do community detection.
Um I don't know. Yeah. So this just
shows with this label propagation is um
one that is really fast. Um it's really
fast. It scales really well but it's not
but it's mathematically really really
simple when we talk about label
propagation. And so in this case what it
does is it you have a couple of nodes
that have labels and then it will
actually just iterate by assigning it to
its neighbors. Right? Right. So, it'll
go through and it'll sign it'll sign
communities to the neighbors. Um, and so
it ends up being really fast. It's not
necessarily you don't you're not
necessarily looking at that modularity
and that interconnectedness.
But if you're looking for something
that's going to run pretty quickly,
label propagation is a really easy way
to do that. This is going to be more
about um Pagrank. I know probably
everybody's heard Pagrank. Um, page rank
is more of a an importance algorithm.
But what I want to do now is let's go
back to is everybody set up on sandbox
at this point? Everybody who wants to be
on sandbox? Martin is here if anybody
needs help with their sandbox. All
right. Um, once you log into sandbox and
you open it, uh, you can see that we we
have the IDE, our browser IDE, and then
on the left hand side we we have all of
the walkthroughs. Um, and it's really
straightforward. we just kind of walk
through the way that graph data science
works in Neo4j is the first thing that
we do is we create a projection. So all
that a projection is is it's a subset of
the graph that's brought into memory on
which you can run your algorithms. So,
think of it, you know, of a a Panda's
data frame in your notebook that you
pulled in from your database, right?
It's something that's live and in memory
and it's something that you can run the
algorithms on. So, that's just one thing
to know is that you're going to pull in
your graph projection, you'll run the
algorithm on the projection, and then
there's a variety of ways that you can
show or interpret those results.
Uh the data that we have that
automatically loads into the graph data
science um uh I can't speak the graph
data science sandbox is airline data. So
it's got different airports, airlines,
things like this. Um you can dive into
this if you want. Um but what I really
want to do today is to just give you an
idea of how graph data science works in
GDS. Um and just show you a few of the
different areas that we can go ahead and
do that. So, um, when you're working in
the sandbox IDE, if you click, you see
when I click on the code here on the
left, it automatically puts it into the
cell up here on the right, and then you
just run that. So, call DB schema is
just going to give you a visualization
of whatever the data model of what's
currently in the database that you're
working with. Um, it's a really good
tool that, you know, we use all the
time. It's kind of like your overview.
Yeah.
So
obviously, you know, you're here for a
graph. You've probably run some cipher
queries before. So we're going to start
with the most basic. So like when we're
running cipher queries, um who here
loves learning new languages, new
computer languages.
Yeah, right. All the time. Yeah, I just
need another thing to learn. Um, for
those of you who may not be familiar
with cipher, the good news about cipher
is it's pretty logical. Um, and it's
pretty similar to I I can understand how
it is an evolution of SQL. But really
what the where the evolution comes is in
this piece here which is in the match
statement. So the match statement is is
you just want to be thinking always when
you're interacting with your graph or
where you're starting to think about the
projection of what is the data that's in
there and which parts are going to have
what I need to answer what I'm looking
for. So you know we've got a
straightforward match, you know, give me
three airports. Um you'll see this in in
this browser uh as well as in our
workspace browser. When you get a
response from Neo4j, it's going if it
cann default to graph, but you'll also
have tabular or you can get text data or
code outputs. Um, and those are also
downloadable. So, if you want to
download any given cell, you can do that
as well. But we can also look at things
like the distribution of airports. So, I
want to know which airports on a
continent and then I want to be able to
um calculate those. So, all that we're
saying is give me the name of the
continent and how many airports are on
that continent.
Oh, 989 airports with no continents.
Something is seriously wrong here. I
think we have some uh some data
problems.
>> North America.
>> Oh, isn't that sad? Sorry.
I You'd think I would know the
continents. You know, I've been a data
scientist too long when as soon as I see
NA, I'm like, well, that's weird. Sorry.
Didn't mean to shout at everyone. Yeah.
Sorry, Martin. Thank you. I maybe I'm
maybe I'm still jetlagged. Um and then,
you know, we can obviously do different
types of um you know, our aggregate
data. We can do our basic EDAs of our
max, mins, all of these pieces. Um we
have statistics on lengths of flights,
right? So again, we're looking at these
airport routes, minimum distance,
maximum distance, average distance. So,
you know, anybody who's coming from a
data science background, what what I'm
trying what I want you to see is that
all of those standard summary statistics
are still really easy to calculate out
of your graph
questions so far. All right,
lots of words, but all the words here is
just telling us that what we need to do
is in order to run an algorithm, we
actually need to create a projection. So
things that you want to look at um and
when you go I should probably bring up
our documentation. I can show you. But
whenever you're looking at documentation
within the the graph data science
library, it's going to have different
requirements or parameters for the
algorithm that you're running. So does
it need to be directed? Does it need to
be homogeneous? Can I have multiple
labels? Whatever the requirements are
for that algorithm to run well, they're
going to be given to you. And what you
want to do is you want to make sure that
when you're creating the projection to
run that algorithm, you take that into
account. So for example,
right now we're looking at um like this
here is we're actually going to create
the projection, right? So graph project.
You're going to give that graph a name
like whatever you want it to be in
memory. That's a variable name. You're
going to have some information about the
nodes and information about the
relationships and what's coming into
them here. And then the yield is going
to be give me back the the graph name
the actual projection node counts etc.
So if we run this this is not this is
the overview sorry. So in this case when
we want to run it so we want to graph
project. So roots is going to be the
name of the projection. So that's what
you're going to be doing running your
algorithms on is the roots projection.
You want the nodes that you're listing
are is airport and you want the
relationship has root and you're going
to bring back like I said the graph name
the projection etc. And so in this
particular projection all that we're
bringing in is the airports and their
connections to each other.
Clear all this. All right.
um if it's too fast or too slow like if
you're ready for more stuff you just let
me know. So once we run this what's
going to happen is um that is going it's
immediately going to live in memory.
Sometimes um you know if if you come
from the Python side of things we love
notebooks and we love rerunning cells
all the time. It's like you know secret
pastime. Um if you try to repro if you
try to repro the same name you're going
to get an error that says oh this
projection already lives in memory. So
it's the most common error that we see.
So if you see that it just means that
projection already lives in memory. You
don't need to create it again.
So you can also see if you want you can
see which which things do I already
have. So we can see that we've got this
graph. So um graph list just lists your
projections or you can say I just want
to see what's in roots. So this will
just give me the information on that
particular projection. So just you know
what you have available. Now the other
thing to keep in mind when we're running
the algorithms on this projection, we
decide what we want to do with the
output when we call the projection.
You're like, why would you do that? Just
run it and then tell me if I want to
keep it. And we have that because
there's there's four different things
that we can do. We can have um stream,
write, mutate, or stats. So um in the
last one, stats just gives you a single
summary statistic. Sometimes people are
just looking for the summary. So that's
the last one. But you have three
different ways. You can stream the
output which means just show me what the
output is but don't do anything with it.
We can write the results um which is
going to like return the the the record
of those or we can actually mutate and
the difference is are we changing what's
in the projection or are we changing
what's in the database. Okay. So on
mutate the Yeah. So just be careful when
you're using mutate. The mutate doesn't
change the database itself. It just
changes what's in the projection. So if
you actually want to write to the
database, you're going to use the write
schema. You're going to use the write in
your in your call.
So let me go back. Go back. Go back. Go
back. Okay. So this is so um this just
tells you a little bit about the way
that we do it is like you might see that
there's a tier. It's just a breakdown of
what's actually in uh like our
nomenclature on the algorithms. So like
uh in this place like we're we were just
talking about page rank. What we're
going to do
Oh yeah. I don't know why it's telling
me this. We already have this. Yeah.
See, there we go. All right. We'll do
this. All right. Um and so now what
we're going to do is we're going to do
page rank. And page rank is a way of um
understanding how important a node is.
And the way page rank works is it it
calculates it based on how connected the
connection of influence to other nodes.
[sighs] And page rank is iterative. And
you know this is one walkthrough. So if
we start out where every node has a
value of one and we go through the
iteration, what it will do is it will
say okay, I'm going to take all the all
of the sort of weight and influence of
those nodes and I'm going to pass it in
the direction of where it goes. So in
this case, this power of one is going to
go to this node and this power of one is
going to get split between this node,
that one and that one. That one goes
there. So really what it does is it says
give me all the the weight of influence
that I have and distribute it evenly
across all of my outgoing nodes. So when
we do that the next round we see okay
well this ended up at two that one
nothing's going to it so it's not
getting any influence coming towards it.
Um and then that's just going to keep
running until eventually it settles. And
so this is just one example of how page
rank works and what's actually happening
under the hood. So when we run page
rank, what it's going to do is it's
going to look at all of the connections
um and see where that influence is
within each of those. Yeah, please. Um
where those are going to run. And so
what we did here is what we saw is we're
streaming the output. And streaming the
output just means we just want to see
it. So we want to see um you know Dallas
Fort Worth has really high page rank you
know and it makes sense these are hubs
right there's lots of things coming in
and out um so that's what's happening
with page rank here
um in write mode like we said write is
going to actually write it back to the
database so that's going to change
what's in the database and now if I want
to know that it actually confirmed that
we can go through and say okay let me
actually check the database for this
page rank and we'll see that page rank
is actually on the node itself.
Good, good, good, good. All right.
Um, all right. So, we talked a little
bit about we talked a little bit about
Luane and how Lou works and really like
we're doing the same thing. We're going
to now run that Lou vein. We're going to
try and find the modularity of each of
those clusters. We're going to stream
that, which means we just want to look
at it. And what we want to look at is we
want to look at within each of those
communities, which community has the
most um the most nodes within it. So,
Luain sometimes takes a little while to
run depending on your data set. I will
tell you Lane and GDS still runs faster
than in network X, but you know,
sometimes you got to throw back a little
any network X like you know, recovering
from there. All right. So, we have
community ID 3321. There are 697
airports. It looks like they're mostly I
mean, yeah, these look like they're
mostly by um by continent, not
surprisingly, right? Those are all US
cities, European cities, etc. And that
kind of makes sense. Like we would
expect we would expect those kinds of
communities to cluster together. And it
tells us how many there are.
Um then the thing the next thing we're
going to look at is we're going to look
at node similarity. And in this case
what we're trying to figure out are
which of these which of these things are
are the most similar. Um what we're
doing here is we're going to actually
look at the basics. We're going to take
it we're going to stream the routes. Um
and we want to look at each of those
each of those individual airports and
see how similar they are. Now, there's
lots of different ways that you can
check for similarity. Um, you can look
at the node embedding itself. In this
case, um, you know, we're looking at the
ones that are the the most the most
similar, right? And what it's going to
do is it's going to give you each of
those and you're going to get a
similarity score. We use this like I
said before when we're running um when
we're building genai applications and we
are creating the the clustering of the
documents. Initially what we'll do is
we'll run node similarity but we'll run
it on the vectors of the on the property
vector of the node and then we'll run
the similarity on that and then we use
that to then create the then we run
luane to create those documents
clusters. So they're originally based on
similarity and then further further
clustered for luane. Does that make
sense?
Anybody here working on genai apps?
No. All right, then I'll stop making
those references.
Um all right. Yeah. And so here we
clearly see we've got you know we've got
what is it like I don't know I don't
even know where these are. Alborg is
similar to
con co. I'm not sure. I'm not sure why
they're similar, but they are. Um, and
we can stream these, right? So, in this
case, we want to actually say, well,
just give me the top three. Don't give
me all the similarity scores. Just give
me the top three. And we'll do that as
well.
You can do the top one. You can do them
as a threshold. There's any number of
ways. Um, the other thing you can do is
you can do um like have a threshold. So,
like a degree cutoff, which means I want
um a minimum degree of
wh
what just happened?
It's my computer. It's not you.
Oh, it says I'm Yeah, I have energy.
That's weird. I don't know what
happened.
>> It's just me. It's just me breaking
things. like we're good. Um, so yeah, so
you can have you can have degree cutoffs
like it can't be more than so many hops
away. It could be that you want a
similarity cutoff like I only want a
threshold greater than X. Um, these come
into play a lot when you're looking at
um like different types of
recommendation engines, right? I I don't
want necessarily I want everything
that's within a certain distance or I
want the top X. Like it'll just depend
on your use case. Any
questions so far?
All right. Can I ask you all an honest
question? Who here has seen something
that they haven't seen before?
You This is some of this is new for you.
>> Oh, good. Okay. I was like I I'm always
curious when I come to graph
conferences. I'm like, have you seen all
this before? Like is it boring? Like I'm
just trying to I'm trying to gauge
what's what's helpful for people. Okay.
So, it's good. Um,
any questions so far?
What I'm hoping we have right now is an
idea that you have a graph
and there are things that we can learn
and extract from the graph by using
different kinds of algorithms. Right?
The other thing I want you to know is
you need to do a projection. So, you
need to understand what in the graph do
I need to run this. So when I'm thinking
about um like what are you working on
right now? Are you working with graphs
right now?
>> Not so much. Not so much. Um had you I
think you had mentioned you were using
page rank on something. Does anybody
have a use case right now they're
working on that they can talk about? Can
you talk about No, you can't. Most
people can't. Um yeah. So the so what I
want you to think through is what is it
like
what is the connected data that I have
and what is it that I wish I knew about
it right because ultimately we're trying
to find like are we looking for things
that are similar are we trying to find a
way to get from one place or another
right it could be that you're working on
supply chain data and you're like where
is the actual bottleneck where might
that
you know, we use page rank. Um, you
know, for anybody, does anybody know
like the history of Google and page
rank, right? I mean, where yeah, where I
mean, where Google really like started
to sing early on is that it said, well,
not every web page is the same, right?
Not every web page just because it has,
you know, this title. What I want is I
want I want the ones that are the most
influential to be at the top of the
list. And so their initial, it's much
more complex now, but their initial
algorithm was really just a page rank
algorithm of, you know, if everybody's
pointing to CNN for reference, then it's
probably going to be more important. And
that's where page rank sort of came into
the common culture really through
through Google. And so that that way of
understanding which nodes can be
important. Um, page rank is one of those
ways that that came up.
>> Yes.
Yeah, mostly you don't have like
graphs where you only have one label and
relationship.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> But in the earlier presentation there
was a good example from white works.
>> Oh yeah.
>> They use like an artist network. So you
have an artist that plays drama.
>> Yep. But then if you have something like
this, how do you figure out for example
the most influential genre? Because it's
always goes through an artist. there's
no
>> I mean and this is where this is where
the creativity comes in is you can
there's there's a couple of different
ways that you can think about it is
sometimes what we'll do is we'll have
ways where we create like a newer type
of relationship
um or like a a what we call a secondary
relationship. So for example um one of
the things that comes up is we like
co-authors. I've got a paper and it's
authored by these two people. There's no
relationship between those two people.
But then what I can say is I can say,
oh, I can create a new relationship
called co-author. And then I can have an
entire network of just the connections
of those co-authors. So you could say,
you know, because really you'll have any
given piece is going to be in multiple
genres, right? So you could do something
where you start creating connections
between genres, right? So, if I've got
maybe I've got 10 songs that are, you
know, hip-hop and R&B and five are
hip-hop and, you know, country, you can
use those to create new relationships
among those. So, that's one way that you
could do it if you're trying to run an
algorithm that really should only be run
on a single label
>> and and then for example for the page
rank to keep the intent because there's
no direction, right? If you call
something, you're not calling me
Yeah. Well, I mean, then it has to then
you have to figure out like is page rank
really the right algorithm for what I'm
trying to what I'm trying to discern,
right? I mean, is it like what is it
that you're trying to figure out? Like
are you trying to figure out what what
would be the problem you were trying to
solve in that case?
>> What's the most differential
author that between that? [snorts]
>> Yeah. I mean in something like that like
sometimes what we'll do is um like
centrality can be one way of actually
calculating importance really well um
because you know
tech well would it be between this like
I'm not sure um you know my husband does
a lot of work with idea contagion and so
what he tries to do is he tries to see
of everything that's currently here if I
traced back all of those Like if you go
through say historical citation. So I
have this paper which cited that paper
which cited that paper which cited that
paper. Right? If you think about it
there is actual influence there. So when
we're trying to figure out like what is
influence there needs to be some sort of
lineage or connection in order to see
what that influence is in your case.
Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. [gasps] Right. So, so again, if
you you just have to step back and think
through what is the data that I have and
what what would what would merit
importance, right? In the web, it's
really clear if you've got a lot of
people linking to you, that's going to
merit importance. If we're looking at
historical citations, we can clearly see
this paper, you know, like you can
follow it back through the citation. So
you just have to figure out based on the
data that you have where where does the
influence actually live or where can it
be imagined.
Does that make sense?
>> Yeah. I mean, if we're talking about
music, there's lots of things that you
could do. Like you could do I mean,
again, it's a totally hypothetical
thing, but you know, you could do
something like um you look at a song and
you run similarity, like you do a node
similarity on the song and then you put
them in in some sort of an order, right?
So, you can say, "Oh, well, there all of
these new songs are very similar to this
song that was temporarily was was
earlier, right? So you can add that
dimension of of lineage that way. So
depending on what it is that you're
looking at, you just have to figure out
in the in the real world, how would I
imagine influence and then say, is there
a way that we can represent that in the
in the relationships that we have or is
there natively something that we can can
leverage?
Is that helpful?
>> You looked like you had a thought on
that, did you?
No. Okay. All right. your it looked like
your brain was working.
Okay.
Um yeah, so centrality. So speaking of
centrality and importance, right, we
talked a little bit about uh page rank,
page rank, we talked about this, we
don't need to talk about this again. Um
and yes, to your point, monopartite
graphs, it's anonymous between
essentiality like one of our faves. Um
in this case it says a node is important
if a large number of shortest paths pass
through it. And what does that actually
mean? So in this case when we see which
of these nodes is really important in
order to get from one node to another
you can't get to a blue node from a red
node without passing through this point
in the middle. Right? So it just means
if we looked at all of the shortest
paths between all of the the nodes that
we have more of them would go through A
than any other one. So when we think
about a company we can say oh is the CEO
the most important person or is it you
know the person who talks to engineering
and marketing right there's only one
person that's connecting those
companies. So when we think even about
centrality and importance, we have to
think through what what is it that
matters, right? Page rank is going to be
a different type of importance than
centrality. So um my co-worker and I
actually did uh did a Star Wars talk one
time about centrality algorithms. And
the idea is if you're trying to disrupt
a supply chain, you're going to want to
go to the point that has the highest
between the centrality. If you're trying
to identify where there's risk in your
supply chain, you're going to want to
look at your betweenness centrality,
right? Because this is the place these
are the points where you really want to
have res redundancy. These are your high
failure points or high failure risk
points. So, um centrality can be a great
way of seeing different types of
importance, right?
Uh yeah. So, it take it calculates the
shortest weighted path between every
pair. we go breath first, you know, it's
a score based on each of these. Um,
it doesn't scale well. It's not the
fastest for really large because it is
based on um, you know, pair-wise
calculations. You can do random sample
like approximations and different pieces
like that. But like we said, it's really
good for bottlenecks, vulnerabilities,
pieces like that. We do have lots of
other centrality algorithms. We talked a
little bit about page rank um you know
closeness like all the all different
types of centrality algorithms and the
key is to really think through when
you're looking at the documentation of
the algorithm itself like is this math
going to express what I'm looking for in
this area of importance. Yeah. Go ahead.
I like that you use the example of how
to destroy a network in relation to
production of logistics because you
actually use it to uh identify enabling
factors in sort of fraud.
>> Yeah.
>> So it's pretty important to find the
facilitators of those networks.
>> Yeah. Absolutely. Absolutely. You know,
I mean Yeah. I mean when you get into
fraud you get into so many super
interesting ways that you can use graph
algorithms. Um
so yeah so we talked about the between
the centrality
um you know again different types of
applications of centrality
uh we don't want to do that we don't
need that how are we doing okay
so in this case what now some of the
things like what you'll see in ways like
now right now we're talking about um
different kinds of uh projections that
we can use sometimes What you want is
you want to actually include a weight on
your projection. So if we think about if
you're building a ways application or
like when we were looking at the London
the London piece, I want a projection
that's actually going to have the time
it takes or the distance between two
pieces or sometimes it's, you know, how
much it costs to acquire that location
or that, you know, next piece, right?
There's some sort of weight on the
actual relationship itself. um that's
going to be important to your either
your pathf finding or whatever your
projection is. And so the way that we do
that is you know like we said before
we've got the name of we pass the name
of the projection we're creating we pass
the nodes the relationships but here
after the relationships we've got this
mapping of relationship property
distance and that is going to bring in
the actual property of distance from the
relationship into the projection. So the
projection is now going to be airports
and has roots but that weight is now
going to be available to run your to run
your um uh algorithm. So in this case if
we're trying to run uh a weighted so
we're looking at shortest path but we're
looking at dystra in particular the
dystra algorithm is a weighted shortest
path algorithm. So what it will do is it
will take um it'll take whatever that
weight is and like we had showed before
like how long it takes and how how
quickly can we get from one place to
another. So if you're going to run a
short a weighted shortest path you're
going to make sure that your projection
has that weight brought in. Um and
that's how we're going to go about doing
that. Why did it did it run? Did it not
run? Nope. Nope. Nope. What? Okay.
Oh, did I not actually? All right. So,
sometimes you you get an error because
you didn't actually create the
projection and you're trying to run an
algorithm on a projection that doesn't
exist. So, that could happen. Um,
why? And now what?
All right, let me try this some more
time. I'm going to go here. Let's run
this. Yes.
Okay, now we should be able to.
Okay, we ran this [sighs]
run.
We now should have Oh, there. Oh, there
it is.
It It did run already.
All right. Okay. So now what we've got
here is we can see we can clearly see
that we've got the actual um we've we've
got the projection and this is showing
us that it is is this showing us that
it's in here? No. Yeah. Yeah. So what we
did is we went through and we have um
we've streamed the Dyster algorithm,
right? And so we've got the results that
are there. And then what we're looking
here is we're trying to find the
shortest path between Denver and MLE.
What is that like Milwaukee or
something? I don't even know. Um, and we
want to do it based on the on the
weighted route. So, how long does it
take to get from or what the distance is
between one and another? And so, what
it's going to do is it's going to show
us that this ends up being the shortest
route. And I don't even know what this
goes through. This is M. Anybody know?
Oh, Mallay International Airport. Does
anybody know where that is?
Anyone? All right. I don't know. Then
it's going to go to go to VNOVA then
Helsinki from Helsinki to Raikyc and
Raikyc to Denver right so that's going
to be the shortest path and this is you
know it's literally what you're doing
with your Google maps and your ways
every day um but that's what's happening
under the hood here so again like I said
this is just a call a shout out to our
documentation so whenever you go in and
look at any of the documentation it's
going to tell you does it need to be
directed or undirected. Yeah question.
>> There are no stupid ideas.
>> Sometimes we need to look at sort of
time.
It's not exactly a time series database
but
>> from the sort of date points [snorts] on
time as a
>> Yeah, absolutely. Yep. And we actually
have people, we were just talking to
somebody about that, they were using um
graphs to check deal progression. And so
what they did is they had nodes that
represented changes in the deal. So when
it went from phase one to phase two,
each of those have a time stamp. And
then the relationship between one piece
and the next is the time delta between
the time stamp on each of those those
changes.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, you could.
I mean then the question is like what is
the relationship like? Is it you know is
it bar to bar? Is it you know beatto
beat? Is it you know how how do you do
that? Um
you know obviously if you have a single
line instrument it's going to be
significantly easier because of course I
immediately go to the piano and I'm like
oh that's not that easy. Um you know
things like that but yeah absolutely
there's lots of interesting ways to take
in take time into account as well.
Um, let me see. I think we're good on
these. Um, oh, and then the other thing
is don't forget to drop your stuff
that's in memory. [laughter]
Um, and that's just going to that's
going to take those out of memory. And
that's going to drop that. Um, so the
the intention of our of our first
portion here is really just to get you
to see a few different things. One is a
variety of the algorithms that we have.
And then the second is to start thinking
about what you want to put into your
projection and what you actually want to
run the algorithms on. Um, does anybody
have any specific questions or something
they've been working on that they've
been struggling with or something that
they want to see? because I've got a
number of other sandbox use cases that
we can actually walk through. Um, which
I think could be give you an insight
into some of the ways that we use those
secondary and creative relationships
when we're trying to run. But if there's
a particular use case or something that
somebody wants to see, you can let me
know now. Otherwise, I'll walk you
through the next piece. Yes,
>> it's not a specific use case, but what
if you
>> just look at a gra algorithms that you
would recommend to execute just based on
nothing that you know about just to get
like an idea how this graph looks like.
>> Yeah, I think um I think sometimes
weekly connected components can be a
really interesting piece because it can
tell you some like overall structure of
the graph. Um it tells you like how many
subsets of the graph do you have? Do you
have you know and then you can look at
say the size of it. So if you've got if
you run weekly connected components and
then you say you know it can tell you
how many disjointed or sort of orphan
nodes might you have um you know and
again where that gets really interesting
is on different kinds of relationships
because most of the time we have so much
interconnectedness and different types
of relationships you're like well it's
not that it's the the subgraph in
general which can be interesting but it
could be that it's the subgraph in this
realm. So think of if we're thinking
about HR data as an example, right?
Everybody's got a boss, everybody's got
subordinates, like there's a certain
amount of organizational structure, but
if you then had additional relationships
that were worked on a project together,
right? Something like that when you look
at different subgraphs is going to tell
a very unique story. And so I think
weekly connected components is a really
important part of EDA in general when
you're trying to understand what's in
your graph. You can run summary
statistics like we have a bunch of
summary statistics that you can run on
graph in general. Um but I think you
know where I come from a data science
background so to me it's the the general
stuff isn't really where the interesting
stories are. It's about what are the sub
are the sub pieces and what if I slice
it this way or what if I slice it that
way like that's where that um like any
EDA that you would do on any kind of you
know data set like I think is really
going to be interesting. So you know for
example like I think weekly connected
components is just an important thing to
just to run in general because I think
it can be really interesting. It's
probably the one that I would use the
most to just get an understanding of
topography of the data. Right. Oh,
sorry. Sorry. We got people who will be
watching this and like, why do I see no
people and no screen and no nothing?
There we go. Oh, sorry. Got to actually
connect here.
Yeah, that's not you. That's me.
>> No, my screen is not happy.
But it's not going to give you anything
because I've got nothing. That's not
you. That's me.
>> Yeah.
It's weird, right?
It says you need to stop talking. Let me
try this.
>> No, please talk. I'll
>> All right. You can see if you can get
that going. Um,
yeah. So, and again, community
detection, I would say, is another
really interesting piece to use because
there's a lot of different ways that we
can use it like for not for the purpose
of the algorithm, but like I said, for
cleaning purposes. So when we're going
through and trying to see do we have
redundancy in our unstructured data, we
run community detection and then we can
look at the similarity. So if I have
like 40 documents or 40 things and the
similar the average similarity score
within that community is really high,
they're all copies of the same thing,
right? Like that's not necessarily going
to be really helpful to me. So maybe we
use that for either cleaning or
prioritizing. So say when I when I get a
result I say okay well don't give me
more than so many that are similar
because it's not going to move you
forward. So things like that. Um I think
that where I think that well I know that
leveraging graph data science for
just general understanding of your data
and like I said what where's where is
the intelligence coming out of it right
we're here at connected data London and
it's all about you know the the the
power of the insight of something that's
coming out of the connection right so In
order to do that, most of the time what
we find is that there's some type of
algorithm that you're going to need to
run to gain that insight, right? We've
got really powerful visualizations. You
can have those temporal visualizations.
You can see, you know, how all the
trains are running through the system
and that's great. But in order for it to
be something actionable, we need to have
some sort of algorithm that we're
running that says, "Oh, this this is
important. This is anomalous. This is
likely to be X. This is a risk point,
right? So the algorithms are where
things are are really going to sing.
Other questions?
Anyone? Um, the other one uh that I just
want to show you is um uh you don't
necessarily have to log into this if you
don't want to is just contact tracing
because I want to show you the ways that
we that you can use those secondary
relationships to start to expand what
your what an analysis is possible. So in
this case
no
just no.
>> Oh yeah I guess I was a little too it's
still it's still thinking. We'll give it
a couple of minutes. Um,
so so much of what I, like I said, so
much of what I find is is interesting in
the graph, it's not usually, and again,
like I don't know if everybody would
agree with me here. I'll ask my Neoforj
compatriots. It's not usually in the
data that's naturally ingested, right?
it's usually in like some form of you
know sold together or you know co-gen or
co-authors or um some way that we can
create connections between homogeneous
things right
so
that's where things get really
interesting to me I don't know Martin
what would you say do you find the joy
in secondary derived relationships in
your data or is it just me I don't know
>> there is there is
finding relationships that I would say
you didn't know existed but were hard to
find. Sorry.
>> No,
>> sorry.
Uh yeah, I was just saying I think there
is a a lot of benefit in
discovering I was going to I was going
to use the words finding relations you
didn't relationships you didn't know
existed but I but you know you know they
exist because they're represented in
your data but they're quite often hidden
in unstructured data or deeply buried or
you know not represented by a true
relationship. It's a Yeah, I think
there's a lot of benefit in it.
>> Yeah. I mean, has anybody done that?
Anybody worked with a graph where you
had your data come in and it wasn't the
native relationship between things, but
the coexistence of things together or
something like that that really started
to be informative? Anybody looked at
that yet?
I mean, if you're doing fraud, I'm sure
you've seen all kinds of interesting
like co-mingling of things that you
didn't know was there.
question.
[gasps]
>> Yeah, I mean it's more it's more just
about you know
secondary relationships which we'll
we'll talk about a little bit. So let me
tell you about what we have in this data
here. So I apologize for putting you on
the spot. That's really unfair. You just
came to like some class and now I'm
asking you all these questions.
Apologies. Um so this is roughly sort of
a it's called contact tracing. You can
think of back in the days of COVID like
somebody was in this state and then they
ran into someone and such and such. So,
um in this case, that's what we're
looking at right now is we're looking at
this schema visualization of um where
someone was like a visit between
different people and where they went.
So, we'll take a look at these um and
what this actually looks like. So, in
this case, we've got roughly 500 people
in this synthetic data set and we've got
half about half of them are healthy and
half of them not so much.
Um, and so
in the this is a very long query, but if
we just take a minute and walk through
it, what we're saying is we want to look
at which person who was sick, right?
Just one where that person visited a
place and another person visited that
place who is healthy. So we've got
someone who's sick going somewhere.
We've got someone healthy going to the
same place. And then what we want to do
is we want to create like we want to
look at the first person is the
spreader, right? And we and we've got
your time stamps, right? So here are
your time stamps, right? So when were
they there? When was this person there?
And we want to go through and take a
look at um what that data looks like. So
for example,
we have this person who they they were
at a place starting at a certain time
and they were there for this duration,
right? So this is showing us when they
showed up and when they left this
particular place. Then we see that
another person was at that same place
during that same time period. Right? So
we can see what this now is allows us to
establish is it allows us to establish a
connection between two people that
wasn't there before based on them being
in the same place at the same time.
Right? So now what we can do is we can
say okay so then we say who has a sick
person potentially then infected and
let's take a look at this. So now what
we're saying is we want to see like the
we want to match the person who's sick
and we want to see all the places they
visited right and all the healthy people
that they may have infected. So this is
showing this is showing that diagram and
these are the places where healthy
people and sick people like came to the
same place.
Now what we want to do is we're going to
simplify all of this by by using visits.
So in this case, we're saying the the
person visited a place, this other
person visited a place. And we're going
to simplify this a little bit,
right? Because we don't we don't
necessarily need the place. We're really
more interested in just the personto
person. We're not as worried about the
the healthy and the sick. So we we now
have this on the visits relationship.
And we want to take into account you
know the time overlap and how long then
this actually calculates um how long
were they in the same place right so
it's going to calculate like what was
the um what was the extent of the
visiture
yes what is the what is the depth of the
exposure right and so now we can start
looking at at a little bit of this so
we've got this person
this person chance was here. He visited
this place. Jefferson was also there. He
visited there. Uh we know the start and
end times. You know, we can look at the
actual the actual tables of what that
looks like. So now we want to see who
has the sick person infected with a time
overlap and simplified visits
relationship. So the start times must
occur before or at the same time of the
earliest end time of the other person,
right? Which makes sense. So, we're
calculating these exposures here and we
can say, okay, this is what this is
going to look like. And now we want um
but then we say, okay, well, it's not
just any exposure like if they're just
in passing. So, let's actually refine it
so that we actually look at those who
were over a certain point of time
together. So, where like the the time
the time piece was at least two hours.
So, then we say, okay, then we're going
to look at what's more likely
and we can do that.
And so then what we say, okay, let's
find the sick person that has visited
the most places since they've been sick.
And again, these are just calculations.
Like we're not even doing crazy data
science at this point. We're just saying
where a person was sick and they visited
a place,
right? And what is the what is that
total number? So we want to look at the
people that visited the most places,
right? Bailey super spreader went to all
these places. A sick person went to all
these places, right? And then what we
want to do is now we want to find the
connections between the actual sick
people because people became sick at a
at a a certain point, right? So let's
just look at the sick people. And what
this is going to allow us to do is it's
going to say like, okay, we've got this
person who was sick, this other person
that was sick, and we want to see all
the places they visited together. And so
we use that visits. And then this
actually shows um like all of the all of
the sick to sick connection, right?
All right. And so then we can do things
like calculating which healthy person
has the highest risk. And again, these
are it it's when we think of data
science, it's not necessarily always
going to be a graph algorithm, but is
there some more sophisticated
calculation we can do to understand
something? So here what we've got is
we've got the healthy person visited a
place where a sick person also visited
the place. But what we want to see is we
want to see of all these healthy people
who had the most facetime with sick
people. Right? So who's at the most
risk? And that's what this is going to
do here. So we've got we're matching the
person was at the same time with the
sick person. Then we're gonna actually
collect the maximum time from the first
person's time when they showed up to
when the other person showed up. Right?
That's going to be the max start time
like when either of them who got there
later, right? And then we're going to
look for the minimum of the departure
time. So the last time one person showed
up and the first time one of them left
is going to give us that exposure time,
which is what we have here. Then we want
to say, okay, where the start time is
greater than the end time, which makes
sense, let's actually sum up all of
those minutes of exposure, and that's
going to give us the overlap time. So,
how long, how many minutes was this
person exposed,
right?
Math, math, numbers, calculation things,
right? I mean, these take a while
obviously because we're looking at
different pair-wise relationships. We're
looking at um you know the overlaps
things like this.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You could very easily do
that. So instead of having to do that,
you just create a new relationship that
says exposure and you have it go from
the person who was sick to the person
that was healthy and the number of
minutes they were in the same place.
Right? Then you've got that graph and
you can do shortest path tracing, right?
Like that's something where you could
trace all the way back through. Oh,
you're good. Okay. Um, so again, in that
case, we are using this math to
understand something, but you can use it
to create a new relationship that then
you can do new things with. So now,
similar to that citation tracking, you
can actually track through like was
there a super spreader, right? like was
there a a person who had the most
influence, right? Um so you can
certainly do that. And again, we're
still looking this is this is a a
similar thing, but we're just looking at
the healthy person who's had the most
exposure. Um and we're actually looking
at that visualization here. So that's
another one. Um I want to actually skip
these. Okay. So what I want to show is I
just want to show um like a couple other
things. So now what we're saying is
we're going to start creating we're
going to say where we these two people
visited the same place right and where
there was like some sort of overlap
right we want to actually start creating
a relationship between these people that
will show the will show that exposure
and that risk right so what does that
actually look like so we can see this is
going to be a list of all the people and
that had overlap app with another
person, right? So, person one, person
two, and then how long they were how
long they were exposed to each other.
And what we're doing now is we're
creating this relationship meets, right?
It's exactly what we said. Create the
relationship meets and what that
exposure time is.
exposure
relations.
>> Yeah, I mean what you can do is you can
just create the relationships and then
when I do a projection say give me a
projection of where one person was
exposed to another person for a minimum
of X and run the algorithm just on that
subset. Right? So this is exactly what
we're talking about is creating a
secondary relationship that you can then
use in your algorithm. So don't feel
like oh my graph doesn't have that.
Think about what is a logical way that I
can expose what's in there and put it in
a structure that I can use to run this
algorithm. Yeah.
story. I looked at [snorts]
some of the legislation concerning
bankruptcy
>> and I found that the law isn't just the
law. There's also time in the law.
>> Something is illegal
and then it's not.
>> Yes.
>> And naturally our data set is thus
biased because we have people who
frame.
>> Yeah. I made a quick analysis of people
who were outside that time frame but
within a reasonable distance
>> in relation to bankrupt companies
>> and then listed them by the number of
times they have been in that relation
that was
>> interesting.
>> Yeah. Because when you have that sort of
a natural cutoff you're not going to see
it right you're like oh well it wasn't
within this time period it's not going
to come up. You're like okay well let's
expand it or let's look a little deeper.
Let's see that. Yeah, that's super
interesting. Um,
oh, the beauty of time. Let me see what
else do we have here. Hold on.
So, now we've got this homogeneous graph
of people exposed to each other, right?
We have people and meets. So now what
we're going to do is we're going to
create a projection of those people who
are meeting people and I'm going to run
page rank on it.
Right? One way of understanding
centrality is page rank. What's the
biggest influence? Oh, no. What? Did I
not run this? Oh, it hadn't finished
running. Sorry.
It's probably Let's see. Who is this
person?
Does it tell us who it is? Oh, this is
the the overall outputs of the of the
actual page rank. Sorry, we got to
actually run who is we got to run it.
Um, so now we can say, "Oh,
Rick, Rick, you're really mucking up the
system for people, right?"
He really did. I mean, genuinely, he's
like, he's got a page rank of 27, right?
Like, he was he must have been out a lot
and spent a lot of time when he was out.
Like, what are you what are you doing?
It's a good thing your neighbors don't
know data science and it's not 2020
because, you know, you'd be like like
protesting outside your door. Um uh yeah
so then we can actually like I said we
can look at the person nodes by these
ranks right so let's actually take a
look at it so you can actually um you
can actually go ahead and you know look
at them and like size them by page rank
or different things like that so you can
actually look at those connections as
well so I mean what is Rick doing here
oh no there's Carmen
oh where where is he there he is I mean
he visited a lot of places right like he
was like out running errands. He was a
busy guy, right?
Oh, he owned a grocery store. Well, that
could be part of the problem. Rick's
grocery store. I don't want to be
shopping there in 2020. Um Oh, yeah. Oh,
yeah. It gets messy fast. Let's not do
that. Expand all the things. Um but this
is another way. So then if we look at if
we look at centrality and importance
like who's the one person when we look
at all these connections of these people
and all of these different visits like
was there someone who was crucial in
maybe connecting one community and
another right and so in this case let's
see who we have we're looking at between
this centrality
Annabelle
Annabelle was very important and even if
maybe it was just like because if you
think about it. If you've got, you know,
one city that's got a thousand people
and another city that's got a thousand
people, if Annabelle's the only one that
went from Paris to London and brought it
with her, you know, that's that's a
pretty high importance factor. And it
doesn't necessarily mean that she saw a
lot of people, but she created the
connection between those communities.
That was important.
Um,
yeah, and we can actually, let's
actually take a look at what that looks
like structurally.
I don't know why.
I don't know why it looks like this.
Let's see. Oh, because it's limiting 50.
Yeah, Annabelle, we'd have to look at uh
I mean, we could do we we could look at
a diagram of just all the people and see
sort of where she is among among
communities as well. Um and that could
be interesting. So, again, thinking
through these kinds of algorithms that
we have and what can we learn about them
and what can we take action on and what
is possible, right? understanding what's
happening there. We just got a couple
more things to take a peek at. Um, we
can run, you know, we talked about Lou
vein. We can run community detection.
So, let's look at all of the people that
are interconnected, right? Maybe you've
got like can tell you my son's hockey
team, every kid on that hockey team had
pneumonia this fall, right? Because it's
all just like germs all over each other.
Same kind of thing. So, in this case,
what we're doing is we're creating um,
you know, meetings with time. We've got
a person. We're doing an undirected
orientation. We are bringing in the
weight of how long they were exposed to
each other to help understand that uh
that tightness of that community.
So we will create this projection. And
then what we're going to do is we're
actually we ran community detection and
now what we're going to do is we're
going to write those community numbers
back to the actual data set. So again,
write is going to um be writing those
back. And now, so now there's going to
be a new um property called community
and that's going to be the community
identifier on each of those people
nodes.
Again, Louane takes a hot second
or not.
There we go. All right. So
yeah, let's see.
Let's go to here.
Let's actually look. So now we're
looking at each of these different
communities and how many people are in
those communities. So, you know, we our
biggest community has 112 people. Um we
probably have some communities that are
significantly smaller,
right? Um let's uh can we visualize? Oh,
yep. Yeah, it's not going to be on
there. Um yeah, if you wanted to, you
could definitely go back through and um
actually visualize what you're seeing
here, right? Like you can color them by
community and see what those look like
and um take a look at those different
types of centrality scores. But you
know, even in this case, we are we
looked at how many different types of
algorithms. We looked at path finding of
how can we trace from one person to
another. We can look at community
detection of you know where are the
groups of people. We can look at you
know derivative relationships that built
all of this which is where were they
mutually exposed. So when you think
about your graphs that you're working on
or you think about your connected data
are there other pieces or other
relationships that can be helpful in
solving another type of problem
that's all I have for today. We still
have probably like another I think we
have another 20 minutes, right?
>> Do we have more time?
>> Yeah. And now and now it's more just
about sort of like when you if you I
would say when you think about the the
use case you had when you were coming
in. [gasps]
Can you think of looking at some of the
ways that we've looked combinations of
algorithms? Is there something that
you've thought like that you might want
to try? Has anybody come up with
something that they're like, "Oh, well,
maybe I can try this or maybe there's
something possible with that?"
No.
Anybody have anything they want to
noodle on or questions you have?
No questions.
All right. I am here like we're going to
be here for until the end of time. So if
there's something you do want to look
at, if there are any other algorithm or
algorithm types that you want me to walk
through, I can certainly do that as
well, just let me know. Um otherwise,
what I would say is um to learn Oh, did
I really just Yeah, I just closed those
slides. Let's not do that. Sorry.
Here blah blah blah. Um, what I would
say is, um, to to learn more, we have,
uh, really lovely classes that are
available on graphacademy.com.
One of our folks who runs graphacademy,
Martin, is here. He actually just did a
workshop before this one. Um, all the
courses are free. You can dive into
anything. The other thing I would say is
if you have questions for me personally,
always just feel free. I'm on LinkedIn,
Allison Coette. I'm really easy to find.
I The fastest way to find me is always
DM me on LinkedIn if you have any
questions about either something we
talked about today, something you come
to a blocker on, you're like, I just
need another brain who knows the space
and wants to think through something
with me. Um, definitely don't be shy
about reaching out anytime.
Sound good? Awesome. In that case, I'm
going to say thank you all for your time
and attention. Larry, anything else we
need to do? Oh, no. All right. Thank you
all so much.